i
y
y bueno hablemos de ideas que para eso
estamos aquí que es el parricidio el
parricidio es el asesinato a los padres
a los hijos o al cónyuge
vamos a hablar de ideas un poco locas
pero eso está todavía más loco en lo que
venimos a plantear pero qué pasa si
tomamos un concepto y lo convertimos en
algo ideológico qué pasa si convertimos
el parricidio en un partido ideológico
el asesinato de las ideas impuestas por
la sociedad de las ideas impuestas muy
veces buenas por nuestros padres por
nuestros tutores por nuestros profesores
maestros amigos primos hermanos y toda
la sociedad que normalmente nos rodea el
plantear el asesinato de todas estas
ideas es el primer paso para poder
construir una vida única
en méxico el promedio de edad y el
promedio de vida de una persona es de 74
punto 95 años o sea 75 años pero la
muerte biológica es solamente el último
paso de la vida o de la muerte de una
persona cuando volteamos a ver todo esto
probablemente digamos bueno pero la
muerte en esencia es la muerte física no
cuando una persona pues deja de existir
como ser humano pero preguntémonos cuál
es la diferencia del ser humano con otro
tipo de seres como por ejemplo un animal
la diferencia entre el ser humano y otro
tipo de seres principalmente es la
capacidad de razonamiento si nosotros
traducimos esa capacidad de razonamiento
en libertad de pensamiento nos vamos a
encontrar que con todas las barreras que
tenemos de entrada desde que somos
chicos hasta que empezamos a tomar parte
de la sociedad
pues nos encontramos ya en una
incubadora de ideas ajenas y perdemos
muchísimo la libertad de pensamiento
cuando perdemos nuestra libertad de
pensamiento perdemos en esencia lo que
nos diferencia de otros seres así que
podremos existir biológicamente pero
probablemente en nuestra esencia esté
completamente irak o cuando nos
planteamos todo esto
pues vale la pena preguntarnos cuando
éramos pequeños a los cinco años y nos
preguntaban oye tú qué quiere ser de
grande y muchas veces sigamos yo que sé
astronauta si dejamos de ver las cosas
un poquito
teóricamente en el renglón y nos
enfocamos psicológicamente en entender
por qué un niño de cinco años que ir a
la luna nos vamos a dar cuenta que
porque el niño de cinco años todavía no
tiene las barreras sociales impuestas
por todos estos tipo de padres
profesores directores etcétera y la luna
es lo más imposible para el niño es
salirse del planeta tierra y sin
importar que la luna está fuera del
planeta tierra
el niño decide
ir a ese objetivo a lo más difícil que
hay porque todavía no tiene involucradas
ideas ajenas y está viviendo de ideas
propias sin importar cuáles son las
barreras sociales las barreras
económicas laborales o cualquier otra
otro tipo de cosas entonces el niño
empieza a crecer y empieza a adquirir
nuevas ideas nuevos conceptos se empieza
a topar con que el para partos para
dejar un empleo o que le tiene que dar
una formación y de repente el niño llega
a su último año en prepa y el director
en la graduación dice y jóvenes cuál es
el siguiente paso no y todos gritamos
prácticamente como robots la universidad
en ese mismo momento es uno de los
puntos más importantes de la vida que
nosotros tomamos una decisión que va a
cambiar por completo lo que sigue para
los siguientes 67 años y ese momento es
la decisión de comenzar a vivir en el
caminito que nos dicen mira ahí está el
caminito que tienes que seguir o si
nosotros agarramos y decidimos plantear
no es nuestro propio objetivo y empezar
a construir nuestro propio camino en el
ámbito del emprendimiento que para lo
que estamos hoy aquí y que a mí me ha
llevado a poder comprenderlo de cierta
manera y yo en un momento de mi vida
pues decidí tomar todas estas ideas que
tenía y empecé a decir oye quién soy
quién quiero ser en la vida hacia dónde
quiero ir realmente lo que estoy
planteando mi futuro o las personas que
están planteando un futuro es lo que
quiero hacer yo
y entonces entendí que la luna para mí
podría ser harvard podría ser un google
podría ser crear una plataforma
intercambio activos virtuales y después
una banca digital y pasar por lugares
que nunca me imaginé porque me decían
que eran imposibles en ese proceso me
tocó a mí representar a méxico en un
evento en hong kong de emprendimiento en
donde con uno de mis socios gane el
primer lugar y llegamos los únicos
latinoamericanos y fue algo realmente
maravilloso y entendí que el camino
hacia adelante era empezar a hacer un
poco más loco de lo que era en ese
momento empezar a eliminar la parte
tradicional de mi vida y empezar a tener
estas ideas como en este tipo de foros
tan maravillosos que me nutrían de la
forma en la que me iba a convertir mi
camino en un futuro asesinando todas las
ideas que me habían impuesto socialmente
y con el conocimiento y la experiencia
poder decidir cuáles tomar hacia dónde
quiero ir y con esa locura de tomar el
siguiente paso para poder seguir
adelante y cumplir sus objetivos
muchas veces y no soy el propio tener
tal y tal y es algo que la mayoría de la
gente no tiene no siempre nos enfocamos
en algo más grande de lo que tienen de
al lado y algo maravilloso es si tú
quieres tener lo que los demás no tienen
tienes que hacer lo que los demás no
hacen la línea de la vida y la muerte es
una línea muy delgada y nosotros podemos
ver medicamentos científicamente la
línea de la vida es así y la vida de la
muerte es así cuando nosotros decidimos
adquirir cierta comodidad y no salirnos
de nuestro círculo vicioso de nuestra
zona de confort estamos atendiendo a lo
que la naturaleza llama del relieve
siempre hay un relieve después hay una
depresión y después viene la montaña
nosotros decidimos llegar al final del
relieve nuestro camino y cuando vemos
que para llegar a lo más alto porque eso
es algo seguro si le preguntas a
cualquier persona en el mundo oye tú
quieres llegar a ser el más exitoso del
mundo si el problema llega cuando
empezamos a caminar llegamos al final
del relieve y vemos la depresión
relativa y todas las piedras
así que hay que empezar a caminar a
sudar aquí marcaron todos los pasos del
emprendimiento de manera magistral y ahí
entonces decidimos quedarnos en esa
plenitud de la comodidad esa es la línea
de la muerte cuando una persona vive así
en su esencia está completamente muerto
qué pasa con la vida de repente estamos
acá de repente estamos acá estamos
viendo una época muy difícil como lo
mencionaron anteriormente con el kobe 19
y todos absolutamente todos pasamos de
estar aquí o aquí o aquí o aquí a pasar
aquí y en este momento es el momento de
empezar a hacer un parricidio biológico
porque vemos las noticias y todo es
negativo y te dice tu papá oye pues nos
está yendo mal en el negocio oye pues
fíjate que ya no hay oportunidad ahorita
y de estudiar o ya no está la economía
para poder hacer lo que queríamos hacer
y emprender proyecto queríamos hacer
pero en este punto más bajo es en el
momento en el que tenemos que decidir
hacer el parricidio ideológico para
empezar a escalar hacia adelante porque
somos muy pocos los que hacemos esos
pasos
ahí es donde realmente nos vamos a
demostrar nosotros en nuestra línea en
la línea de la vida tal como se ve en la
naturaleza partiendo de eso pues podemos
entrar en un concepto ya de ideologías
de diferencias sociales familiares entre
muchas otras cosas pero así no necesita
ese asesinato de ideas eliminas el
camino que nos habían planteado y como
se llama aquí el salón empiezas a
plantar tu propio jardín de ideas
empezar a plantar tu propio jardín de
ideas nos empezará a ser un poco más
locos de lo que realmente nos dicen que
tenemos que sea no pero cuando tú te
empiezas a volver más loco al final te
vas a ir dando cuenta que ese es el
motor que está haciendo tu vida esa
semilla que también platicaban aquí
anteriormente que tú empiezas a plantear
internamente porque comprendes que lo
que quieres en tu vida es lo que tú
quieres por eso nos llamamos individuos
porque somos individuales no podemos
vivir de ideas ajenas porque a vivir de
ideas ajenas tu esencia está
completamente
hay muchas veces que preguntamos hoy
cuál es el lugar más rico en ideas del
mundo podríamos pensar que en un lugar
como núcleo podríamos pensar con la
universidad podríamos pensar que es
silicon valley que harvard o cualquier
otro lugar en el mundo pero realmente el
cementerio es el lugar que más ideas
ricas tiene en el mundo en el cementerio
hay libros enterrados ideas enterradas
negocios enterrados canciones no
cantadas libros de los escritos y cuando
volteamos a ver eso pensamos que fue
cuando la persona murió biológicamente
desgraciadamente esas ideas se
enterraron mucho antes de que la persona
muera físicamente cuando comprendemos
esto y nos hacemos un switch mental
tenemos la oportunidad de no enterrar
nosotros mismos nuestras ideas todavía
de agarrar el coraje para salir adelante
hacer el partido ideológico y empezar a
caminar así que repito cuando tú
empiezas a sembrar tu jardín de ideas
empezarás a estar un poco más loco pero
recuerden que con el tiempo
nos convertimos en visionarios
[Aplausos]
o no
[Música]